you know in a movie that's wild enough
to include a T-Rex Spider-Man a cat
Spiderman a Lego Spider-Man and Peter
parked car the spidermobile you think
they'd be smart enough to include
literally the single best Spider-Man
ever put to screen I am of course
talking about supaida man the Japanese
Sentai Spider-Man with the single best
costume a giant robot he's also got
himself a theme song that slaps
we were robbed I tell you robbed Rob
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that'll put its hand on your
shoulder and say hey so Spider-Man's
kind of in an interesting spot in cinema
isn't he full franchise has some of the
best as well as some of the worst
superhero movies ever made even if the
memes are always top shelf look at
little Goblin junior I'm gonna cry but
one movie I don't think anyone saw going
as hard as it did 2018's animated into
the spider-verse telling the story of
Miles Morales as he takes up the mantle
of Spider-Man after his Peter Parker is
killed thankfully he gets himself a ton
of help figuring out what to do in the
form of spider people from various
different universes dragged into miles's
Dimension by the movie's big bad what
felt like it could easily have been a
cynical cash grab turned out to exceed
everyone's expectations it's considered
to be one of the best if not the single
best Spider-Man movie ever made it's
beloved by critics it made a killing at
the box office it won all the awards so
when we all heard that it was getting a
pair of sequels and a cross and Beyond
the spiderverse let's just say that
those movies had a lot to live up to and
thankfully the recently released across
the spider-verse is great seriously when
this movie first got teased I was
concerned that it was just going to turn
into a cameo fest with too much fan
service and while it did Lean in more on
the cameos and fan service than the
previous one it also managed to be a
worthy sequel to one of the best
superhero films ever made even if that
Cliffhanger at the end did leave me a
little bit disappointed also I don't
think this was a problem with the movie
but just one with the theaters that I
saw it in having really bad audio mixing
had a hard time hearing a lot of Gwen
and hobie's dialogue at various points I
thought it was just a me thing you know
I am getting older these days maybe my
hearing's going but then I started
seeing other people bringing it up
online anyway here's hoping that they
get the whole thing resolved even
considering those minor hiccups though
the movie was a visual Masterpiece
throwing us into multiple new universes
and showing us hundreds literal hundreds
of new Spider-Man each with their own
unique visual Aesthetics and styles for
me the standouts had to be spider Gwen's
watercolor world and the incredible 80s
paper cutout animations of spider Punk
also biggest laugh clearly goes to the
Lego Universe which turns out was
animated by a 14 year old kids these
days man you guys are so talented
without a doubt across the spider-verse
took all the ideas from the first film
and turned them up to 11. spoiler
warning for across the spider-verse in
case she didn't figure it out by this
point after the events of several recent
movies including into the spider-verse
Spider-Man no way home and Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse Madness which
yes Doctor Strange is specifically
called out in this movie don't even get
me started on Doctor Strange and a
little nerd back on Earth 1999.99 holes
have started showing up throughout the
Multiverse these have let bad guys slip
into alternate dimensions and wreak
havoc in response Miguel O'Hara the
Sci-Fi Spider-Man 2099 has set up the
spider Society to help police the
Multiverse and bring all these villains
home but when miles wants to join the
spider Society Miguel refuses him at
every step because miles is actually
part of the problem he unintentionally
created the spot a multi-dimensional
villain and the events of into the
spider-verse were never supposed to
happen miles was not supposed to be
bitten by the radioactive spider his
worlds Peter Parker was not supposed to
die miles was never supposed to take on
the role of Spider-Man in the first
place what's even worse that spider that
bit miles wasn't even from his universe
so miles is the original anomaly that
started knocking over all these dominoes
so to help set things straight Miguel
and his spider Society are trying their
best to quote restore the cannon to make
things right by ensuring that the big
events that are supposed to happen to
every Spider-Man across every World
actually happen and if they don't well
then the Multiverse itself could
collapse you know no pressure but see
loyal theorists I have a problem with
his line of logic it doesn't sit right
with me given everything that we see
both in this movie and throughout the
wider Multiverse that this movie sits
within I think Miguel is making a huge
mistake here I think he's wrong about
the whole Canon events thing I also
think he's wrong about miles being the
real danger of all of this and that
error is ultimately going to destroy
everything that we love about every
superhero movie if they don't set things
right we're not only looking at the
collapse of the spider-verse here we are
looking at the end of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so change into your
spider sona's friends and let's swing
into it within the film we're introduced
to the idea of Canon events according to
Miguel these are fixed events in time
that must happen for a universe to
remain stable basically it's the
explanation for why so many different
versions of Spider-Man across so many
different stories all experience the
same things they had to happen for that
Universe to exist now they don't
outright give us an explicit list of
Canon events that have to occur for all
the Spider-Man but they do show us
images of several others within the web
of life and Destiny the ones I spotted
included a spider bite given someone's
superpowers the death of an uncle
ben-esque figure teaching Spider-Man the
lesson that with great power comes great
responsibility connecting with a love
interest sometimes with an upside down
kiss in the rain a wedding to a love
interest a symbiote creating a nemesis
throwing the Spider-Man costume away and
being crushed by Rubble before finding
the strength to lift it Gwen also
mentions that in every other Universe
Gwen Stacy Falls for Spider-Man and in
every Universe it doesn't work out so
that one may or may not be a Canon event
as well but big one the one that applies
the most to this particular story a
police captain close to Spider-Man dies
usually by trying to save a child from
Falling debris this is where the main
conflict of the story comes in miles's
dad is about to be sworn in as captain
of the NYPD and obviously he doesn't
want his dad to die but you apparently
can't bypass a Canon event and Miguel
refuses to let Miles leave to save his
father's life this is something that
Miguel had to learn the hard way
according to Miguel he wanted to be
happy with a family and so he found
himself a universe where that universe's
version of him had been killed he then
stepped in and secretly replaced his
dead self it sounds complicated but
basically he just pulled a Rick and
Morty in fact for being honest this
whole movie is just pulling one big Rick
and Morty spider Society Citadel of
Rick's much it's not a bad thing I'm
just saying anyway Miguel stepping in
was an issue since his death was
considered to be a Canon event in that
timeline leading to that Universe
collapsing people were erased from
existence including Miguel's daughter
who disappeared in His Arms by the end
of it all the universe was gone leaving
Miguel devastated and determined to make
sure that it never happened again this
threat also checks out the movie too as
soon as miles saves Captain singing
membatten and bypasses the Canon event
there a dark hole starts swallowing up
that world all of this sets up a great
conflict between miles and Miguel for
the rest of the movie just like miles we
don't want his dad to die but just like
Miguel we don't want that Universe to
collapse either but here's the thing
when I really sat down and started
thinking about this the whole Canon
events thing I'm not buying it first of
all I have a lot of questions about
Miguel's story here he claims that the
Universe with his family collapsed
because he bypassed a Canon event so
does that mean that Miguel's death was a
Canon event but who then was it a Canon
event for was he the Uncle Ben or the
police captain in this situation or was
he just some random guy was he the
Spider-Man of that world he has the
powers in the title after all would that
then mean that Spider-Man's death is a
Canon event that shouldn't be the case
since Miguel later yells at miles for
getting the Spider-Man of his world
killed and considering how much Marvel
Disney and Sony want to milk this
character until the end of time
something tells me that Spider-Man's
death is not going to be a corporate
approved Canon event that's gonna happen
all all the time additionally how many
times has Miguel seen this actually
happen we only see the one instance so
as Miguel working with a data set of
just one that isn't enough test cases to
make such a weird multiversal Big
Brother organization that's okay with so
many people dying in short it doesn't
make sense and the other Canon events
start falling apart too when you'll
really look at them like speaking of
Miles getting his Peter Parker killed
didn't that disrupt every other Canon
event of miles's universe shouldn't that
Universe have imploded or is that
Universe self-correcting around miles
given how much of an anomaly Miguel
makes miles out to be that probably
shouldn't be the case if Miguel is truly
right in his hypothesis another easy
example would be the Symbiote attaching
to someone and becoming a nemesis for
Spider-Man what's the problem here well
across the spider-verse features a
moment where the spot briefly pops into
the universe of the Tom Hardy Venom
movies to steal some gum but it doesn't
seem like there's a Spider-Man in the
Venom verse for Eddie Brock to butt
heads with considering Eddie doesn't
react to Spider-Man being unmasked when
he briefly crossed over into the MCU
during the post-credits scene for Let
There Be Carnage another example would
be Spider-Man connecting with and
marrying their love interest this
problem comes with The Amazing
Spider-Man films which are directly
connected to this universe through a
cameo with Andrew Garfield sure he fell
in love with Gwen Stacy in his world but
after her death he focuses all of his
time and energy into being Spider-Man as
he explains in no way home you have
someone
time for uh Peter Parker stuff that is
years without a love interest without
building any sort of relationship
without a wedding etc etc and yet as far
as we can tell the world of The Amazing
Spider-Man still hasn't collapsed nearly
a decade after we last saw it thirdly we
gotta talk about the Uncle Ben moments
this death is supposed to be a massive
world shaking event that sets Spider-Man
on his path teaching him all about power
and responsibility now it doesn't
literally need to be a Ben Parker who
dies for miles it was Uncle Aaron for
Gwen it was her friend Peter Parker for
Miguel it looks like it was his daughter
but here's the issue that I find with
all of this Tom Holland's Peter Parker
operates as Spider-Man in the MCU for
literal actual years before he
eventually has his Uncle Ben moment just
to make sure that we're all on the same
page here the writers of the MCU
Spider-Man movies have stated that Uncle
Ben's death in the MCU did happen but it
didn't have the same impact on Holland's
Peter Parker as the others across the
Multiverse instead the importance of
this moment was shifted onto Aunt May in
Spider-Man no way home now you might be
thinking hey it happens eventually so
we're all good but are we just gonna
ignore the timeline here in every other
dimension that we've ever seen ever this
Uncle Ben moment happens within months
even days after he's bitten by The
Spider and across the spider-verse
pavita prabhakar has been operating as
Spider-Man for just six months and
clearly he's already had his Uncle Ben
Moment The McGuire Garfield and Miles
Morales Spider-Man have all had their
uncles die within just days of getting
bit and yet the MCU isn't on the brink
of collapse because Spider-Man hasn't
had his Uncle Ben moment as quickly as
all the other universes but the thing
that really drove the nail into the
coffin for me one of the biggest of
these so-called Canon events has to be a
spider biting someone and giving him
Powers so that Universe has a Spider-Man
to begin with right well we see the
spider bite as the first Canon event
that's explained miles and yet at the
end of the movie when we visit Earth 42
the world where miles's spider came from
that doesn't have a Spider-Man and it's
still there sure it's not in great shape
there's a lot of crime a Sinister Six
cartel that seems to be running things
massive fires throughout all of New York
City but the world itself has not
collapsed now I can already hear plenty
of you furiously typing away in the
comments just because these Canon events
haven't happened yet in these worlds
doesn't mean they won't happen and the
Order of the Canon events doesn't
necessarily need to be the same every
time and believe me I hear you that was
one of my initial thoughts when I was
crafting this Theory too but again it
doesn't line up with what we see in the
movie all thanks to that necessary death
of a police captain close to Spider-Man
bit that drives the whole conflict
remember boom baton starts collapsing
immediately after miles saves Captain
Singh literal seconds after that event
if Canon events don't have to happen at
specific times couldn't Captain Singh or
another Captain have just died later in
the story of that world and yet here is
miles's World which is totally fine it
didn't collapse when Peter Parker died
all of this tells me that what the movie
says about Canon events and the Fallout
of breaking Cannon is wrong Miguel has
misidentified the problem what we're
seeing in these movies isn't the
break-in of Canon it's incursions just
like we've been seeing in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and that is way way
worse than any of these Spider-Man think
it is now if you dropped off the main
MCU after end game you might not know
what I'm talking about here we first
learn about incursions and Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse Madness when
strange is brought before the Illuminati
of Earth 838 Stephen your arrival here
confuses and destabilizes reality the
larger the footprint you leave behind
the greater the risk of an incursion
basically when people from One Universe
cross into another the two universes
start getting pulled together everything
starts breaking down until at least one
of the universes is torn apart at the
scenes killing everyone in it sounds
familiar doesn't it this is an incursion
and they are no joke we see what's left
of a universe after its incursion and
it's a wasteland it is a void of
nothingness this is such a big threat
that the Illuminati think Doctor Strange
merely existing in their universe is a
major risk and that he needs to be dealt
with but hold on why am I connecting
this movie to the MCU Sony is the one
that's making the spider-verse films not
Marvel and that's correct but
spider-verse goes well out of its way to
make sure that there is a connection
established to the MCU and it's not a
blink and you miss it Cameo or offhanded
reference either like I said at the top
of the episode Miguel straight up
references the events of no way home and
multi versus Madness within the first 15
minutes of this movie don't even get me
started on Doctor Strange and a little
nerd back on Earth 1999.99 Earth 1999 is
a designation of the MCU in Marvel
multimedia first called out in the
official Handbook of the Marvel Universe
A to Z no way home connected the older
Sony films to the MCU Multiverse so the
projections of both Andrew Garfield and
Toby Maguire Spider-Man also connect
this movie to them too the spot briefly
visits Mrs Chen from the Venom movies a
world also connected through no way home
and Donald Glover cameos is a variant of
Uncle Aaron suited up as the prowler the
same role that we see him play in the
MCU but the linchpin that 100 slots this
into the Marvel Cinematic Multiverse now
when Miguel begins his explanation of
the spider-verse to Miles he projects a
simulation of the Multiverse one that
looks exactly like how the Multiverse
has been portrayed throughout the MCU
and I'm not just talking oh it kind of
looks like it if you squint at it I
guess this is exactly the same glowing
glimmering white threads branching off
into multiple timelines just like what
we saw in Loki just like what we saw in
Quantum Mania having all of these
connections to the MCU positioning this
as part of the wider Marvel Cinematic
franchise means that we have to bring in
the MCU logic here Sony can't have their
MCU cake and eat it too even if they do
buy two cakes if people from One
Universe crossing over into another
universe is something that causes
incursions that is what we're seeing in
this franchise and it explains
everything it solves all of the issues
that we've been having when Miguel
crossed over into that other Universe
where he died so he could live a happy
life with his family he caused that
world to be erased through an incursion
it explains why Earth 42 the world
without a Spider-Man because our miles
got bit by its spider is totally fine
despite it breaking Cannon no extra
dimensional visitors have spent any
significant time there thereby avoiding
an incursion it also explains what's
happening in mumbatin Miles Gwen spider
punk in the spot basically destroy a
massive stretch of the city leaving a
giant footprint behind the hole that
opens up in mumbatin is the beginnings
of an incursion one that the spider
Society is arguably making worse by I
trying to fix and that's the bitter
irony in all of this in Miguel's desire
to try and fix the problem that he
wrongly identifies as breaking the
cannon what's he do he gathers spider
people from across the Multiverse into
one place and then he sends him on
missions to realities that aren't their
own every single time that he does that
despite her Society is risking another
massive series of these Universe ending
events in short by trying to help the
situation by forcing things to fit a
proper mold to be the right correct way
Miguel has made it exponentially worse
not only increasing the risk of
incursions happening throughout
Multiverse but by indoctrinating a
literal Army of spider people into
simply standing by while innocent
victims die all in preservation of
things being done the right way the
correct way and thematically this Theory
makes a lot of sense the story that I
suspect that the spider-verse franchise
is trying to tell us is that anyone can
be Spider-Man but that everyone is gonna
be doing it their own way everyone is
going to be doing it a little
differently everyone's gonna carry that
responsibility differently but that
doesn't mean that they're doing it wrong
you are your own person and you can
choose your destiny you are not the
product of a bunch of events that came
before you Miguel getting angry at miles
for messing up how things are supposed
to happen yelling at him because he's
not supposed to be a Spider-Man that
could be a stand-in for a lot of the
audience resistant to change an audience
who wants to see the same stories
playing out over and over again the
right way or there can also be a
stand-in for where we are in society
today where certain classes of people
are allowed to do things with their
lives that others aren't just because
they're right or correct just like how
certain people can and can't be
Spider-Man in Miguel's eyes but miles
turns that entire idea on its head being
told that he isn't supposed to be
Spider-Man gives miles the freedom the
permission to stop trying to be
Spider-Man to stop trying to think about
what Peter Parker or Miguel O'Hara or
Gwen Stacy would do and instead to just
be himself to just be miles like he says
In This Moment everyone keeps telling me
how my story is supposed to go nah I'm
gonna do my own and that right there
that is the most heroic lesson that any
Spider-Man across any of the universes
can possibly teach but hey being
Spider-Man has to be rough on the body
especially with that summer heat coming
up miles Peter Gwen Miguel they all need
to stay hydrated to make sure they can
fight regardless of the universe that
they're in and it's never been easier to
do that than with today's sponsor air up
if you've been watching any of the
theory channels over the past year
you'll know that everyone here on the
team loves these era bottles basically
they give you a tasting super powers
they change the way that regular old H2O
tastes without adding any calories or
chemicals to the water just pop on one
of Arab's flavor pods onto the bottle
and Bam suddenly you're tasting
blueberry or cherry all without the risk
of getting bit by a radioactive spider
personally over the last couple months
I've been stocking up on all the summery
flavors like watermelon or lemon or
lemon basil all the things that remind
me of the nostalgic summer parties that
we would have in our backyard with my
family as a kid air up isn't some super
Advanced sci-fi Tech From Another
Dimension where water tastes different
from our world it actually uses real
science to trick your brain taking
advantage of the connection between our
senses of taste and smell by inhaling
the scents from the Flavor pods you're
more or less injecting that flavor into
the water using nothing but your brain
and that right there that is some pretty
awesome Tech Arab also recently added
new steel bottles to their lineup so you
have yourself a durable metal bottle
that stays insulated to take on any
hikes or Outdoor Adventures this summer
it also has a larger capacity which has
someone who drinks a lot of fluids I
really appreciate so if you want to up
your water drinking game why not go grab
yourself your very own Arab bottle and
flavor pods as a special bonus you can
get a 20 discount off your entire
purchase when you use the code film
Theory at checkout or by clicking the
link in the top line of the description
again that is 20 off your entire dang
purchase by using the code
f-i-l-m-t-h-e-o-r-y or just by clicking
the link in the description thank you
again to Arab for sponsoring today's
episode and as always remember it's all
just a theory a film Theory and cut